it really was welcome back to CBS this
morning powerful Santa Ana winds are
fueling two fast-moving wildfires that
exploded overnight in Southern
California strike teams are battling the
so called hillside fire that's in San
Bernardino that's east of Los Angeles
that fire already prompted mandatory
evacuations there in this threatening
homes an out-of-control fire in
neighboring Riverside County has burned
at least four buildings Manuel Bojorquez
is in haruka Valley California Manuel
what are you seeing there on the ground
we're definitely seeing the flames and
of course the wind that firefighters are
having to contend with look at those
flames back there what they're trying to
do is create some sort of break or
containment line but the winds making it
difficult and you can tell by just the
direction that the smoke is going and
how low to the ground it is it's not
billowing up that the winds are
definitely a factor they're trying to
prevent these flames from getting any
closer to homes and ranches that are
just up on the hillside there we have
seen people evacuating and trying to
take their horses with them this morning
this is not the only fire that sparked
overnight there is that fire you
mentioned in San Bernardino about 15
miles northeast of here that prompted
evacuations that one blew up to about
200 acres in just about 30 minutes and
then of course the largest of about a
dozen fires that broke out since
yesterday the one in Simi Valley
that triggered thousands of people
evacuating and also the threat there to
the Ronald Reagan Presidential Library
and Museum which firefighters were able
to save but here we're actually just
getting word from firefighters that they
might try to create what they do is set
a fire to stop the fire set this on fire
try to control it to prevent it from
getting anywhere closer to the homes
creating a buffer so they're moving us
out but we will send it back to you in
the studio all right Manny thank you
very much stay safe out there